greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by out it you gonna need some
supplements you need some alpha brain to
keep that coconut [ __ ] moving one of
the company gives you a product if the
coconuts not cooked and if you don't
like alpha brain keeps the product don't
even send it back won't send you back
your money who does that ship e there's
a hooker suck your dick and if you don't
like the [ __ ] she'd give you the cash
back that never happened well go down to
that combine now press in church BAM get
ten percent off the live at the house I
can't help you with the metal but the
supplements I got you all day long
number two you need a gig you're sitting
there going Joey I'm thinking my joint
you just I'm a fat [ __ ] like you what I
can't what do I use a curtain no you
right now I got you
8685 go to Fuji Sports calm right now
the toughest d out there they start like
89 bucks the all-purpose one get the
nice all-purpose light one they can tug
the tug tug tug let me tell you
something you could kill yourself with
that [ __ ] geek you can hang your [ __ ]
myself remove that's out of the Fuji
[ __ ] gears right now that's a lot of
Fuji sports.com right now press ENTER CH
another one 10% off I'm Johnny ten just
call me Johnny ten percent off that's
what my way do you know I'm saying
anyway get ready to rock [ __ ]
sister Church or what's happening now
coming at you take that [ __ ] melee
who the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with on a Monday morning you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey coming direct
from the studio a death I got my man
professor Joey Alvarado
the inventor Kettle Jitsu you
[ __ ] that's right Stein
invested the light bulb
professor method Kettle Jitsu and the
[ __ ] flying's you aka the Christ
killer aka the Hassid of death
[ __ ] Lisa oh hey guys doing this and
if you came to any of the Vegas shows I
want to thank you had a great [ __ ]
weekend with you guys you know I've been
home after the Netflix thing so that's
exactly why I scheduled it just to be
peaceful go to the seafood bar I saw a
lot of you guys at the bar I saw a lot
of you guys outside smoking reefer later
on that night
listen I had a great time thank you very
much for coming out and supporting
comedy what's going on professor just
hustling man good baby boy yeah that's
not interesting pick tea and that's what
made me call you
sorry interesting picture
me yeah you put a picture you something
like half-nude come after the shower
looking like [ __ ] st. Lazarus without
that st. Lazarus without the dog all
right there he's a man that's a man it's
the medicine Lhasa and he's pretty cut
up Bell so he's kind of prism as the
food was tough it's a face on the cross
he doesn't cut up then he was gonna
[ __ ] our low class he was cut up this
things are tough things are bad yeah
yeah yeah yeah it wasn't no [ __ ] you
know okay there wasn't no saying sorry
yo so you saw the picture but I thought
picture you and it's pretty interesting
you said I'm 47 years old turned 47 in a
couple weeks and you started talking
about a body weight exercises and Kelly
Balboa on this is the best that you've
ever felt in years and it was just
interesting because at the age of like
four years I'm you get this thing
calling sarcopenia something like that
circle yeah penny answer song sarcopenia
where it's the you lose a pound of
muscle every year bad pound of muscle
because it gets replace my fat it's like
when you look at her when you go to a
steak house and you cut a steak and you
see the marbled fat in it yeah it just
gets there's more fat and less muscle
you know for sure I don't know what's
called I mean I don't there's a name for
it with Emily's probably those tweeted
Lila I'm not sorry it's a circle pain
yes of sarcopenia
cyclopædia that's something like that
sarcopenia what is the sarcopenia let's
see I think it's a disease Starkel at
some point in your 30s you start to lose
muscle mass and function that causes
age-related sarcopenia SARC ope and IA I
mean I always knew that like it's pretty
I mean I didn't know what was that 30 I
don't know I just thought like as you
got older I didn't know it started at 30
that's pretty cool I didn't I didn't
know what's called sarcopenia either
yeah they said you can use three to five
percent of your muscle mass each a
decade after 30 yeah a decade is tell
that's why that's why that a lot of
people promote like resistance training
is stuff like that
why it's important so you can maintain
that muscle you know hey so what happens
if you lose muscle obviously like the
fat but do you is there an issue with
your body like is it hard to move and
not necessarily it's just like you know
like like you've seen how like like
Arnold Schwarzenegger viruses or
Schwarzenegger right guys it's not
nearly as muscular and so it kind of
looks like he's like a little bit
shrivel more shriveled up you know but
like because he had so much muscle
before there's no way you can maintain
that forever right that's the thing
about but yours but like yeah so like
you just have to just you know do some
kettlebell training and stuff like that
II eat right and then you're good to go
now you're not gonna have any health
problems right so over 40 what do you
really strive for because I mean a lot
of people listen to podcasts a lot
younger but you know what man if I knew
what I knew today I would have never
stopped lift yeah like I loved all that
[ __ ] I got involved with drugs and
company whatever because even when you
go to prison you take good care of
yourself okay great shakes great shape
between the running and the [ __ ] I
love it I saw Cape Fear with Robert near
home I love these people I give up cars
in jail they give them college for you
you know they give they do it for you
they give you nothing but car prison
they give you everything to fill you you
know bread yeah
shitty white bread [ __ ] great shitty
rice kind of that's all one level below
what you usually [ __ ] get at a shame
[ __ ] restaurant the rumor I heard is
that Jarrod gained a lot of weight back
he said that drinking those six inches
they don't you know eat six inches in
jail 12 in man-wolf or McCarran Airport
you're Jerry what exactly did he did he
must I thought so right yeah yeah he was
invented he was oh my god
how horrible so any we're back we're
back last ten years we've seen you know
maybe the last five years we've seen a
lot of lives just go down the [ __ ]
toilet and land man it's like you're not
the [ __ ] you're about to you know
about to see oh you know one of the
greatest not not to me cuz I was never
really a big [ __ ] I liked them but
then I saw him when I first started
Tommy and he was such a [ __ ] that's the
only word I could describe for me to say
that Cosby really you thought he was a
cup I can recite a piece of [ __ ] when I
matter really that I just stopped like I
never really liked him all that more
than anyway I liked the joke that he had
about buck buck because I related to it
don't one specialty sitting down I'm
kind of related to that but he wasn't
Richard I never got any of his early no
he wasn't Richard Pryor to me so that
moment with me in Colorado Springs that
split moment why people say don't meet
your idols hobby well don't meet your
idols just leave it how it is you don't
need to take pictures nothing yeah I
went he wasn't my idol I just looked up
to him as a yeah of course of course and
as I walked over he was giving a lecture
on comics who worked dirty how they're
just bad for the business and they're
lazy and then he started like just
[ __ ] destroying Eddie Murphy yeah I
turned my back and walked away I go you
know what one thing if he was white and
destroying Eddie Murphy but to be black
and destroying Annie Murphy your own
[ __ ] brother and whatever it are and
what what phase was Eddie Murphy was in
this this has to be 92 you couldn't
touch any Murphy [ __ ] him [ __ ] the cars
dead Larry Denarius when did I know this
was this was this was this is 92 so this
is what is that already delirious came
out already raw came out already [ __ ]
he was at the peak uh you know coming to
America already came out what's the
other one they made when they should
when he shoots delery the pinky toe
[ __ ] nights which is a work of
[ __ ] it's a masterpiece of my work
Eddie Murphy made a couple dog and let
me tell you somethin and four years and
I'm gonna tell you people how it is cuz
I'm honest with you I was in college
when Harlem Nights came out what time
what year that Harlem Nights come on I
think came on 92 Eddie let me tell you
an interesting thing about Harlem Nights
at the time they came out lore over here
89 89 Harlem that's when I graduate
I was in prison let me taste on my own
mates now when I saw a commercial for I
know I'm never gonna watch that movie I
thought it was just a they put a bunch
of black ties together yeah a bunch of
funny black guys together just to put
them together yeah yeah money out of
your pocket is like I watched that movie
reluctantly four or five years later and
today it has to be in one of my top ten
comedies and maybe my top 20 flies Eddie
Murphy was brilliant Richard Pryor was
brilliant [ __ ] Redd Foxx was
brilliant Della Reese was brilliant
[ __ ] not who was the Italian of the
90s you know he wasn't do the right
thing Danny Aiello okay was brilliant
you know every every massage hauling
that - uh-huh
what were we talking about do the right
thing do the Harlem Harlem is nights was
are so yes and no I had a coke they
can't remember in this yeah was he I
think it was I love coming to America I
think that's [ __ ] good well to was
Kenny's day there what are you talking
about coming to America no to shut the
[ __ ] yeah he was lying man he was a yeah
he was what he was a crying man I must
have been like a cameo or something okay
so he wasn't it but he wasn't it yeah he
was okay it's one of the first anymore
well I saw was a training places that
one all classic absolutely is such a
good one man and there's there's very
few movies that like will fully stand up
like some movies now are even star good
but like sometimes you know this doesn't
really stand up I still like it but like
that yeah Oh like it's for you guys 48
hours still stands
oh [ __ ] yeah I got a [ __ ] 48 out
let me tell you something right in
places the prison scene still stands out
as one of the top comedic scenes I've
ever seen in my [ __ ] life okay that's
up there with John Candy and splash
that's how good [ __ ] Eddie Murphy was
in the prison scene when in the
beginning when he's the gay handicap I
could probably see that don't cool and
cool he's an orange I was
like what the quarter blood technique
was in the jail
well he's like so tough he said this is
the line that killed someone karate man
I use think on the inside are you saying
out with this crazy white dude this is
my I love Gentiles they're the nicest
people in the world but you really want
to get my dick hard give me a crazy
redneck Gentile I'll SiC on people this
guy was my personal Bulldog just out of
love he just loved me and I loved him
but he loved doing cocaine he loved two
things in life doing cocaine and [ __ ]
women and I'm gonna tell you something
to both to your face is never if
somebody do two things that good is he
and he used to I used to see the woman
he used to front on a daily night 11:00
one night he [ __ ] this millionaire
trick in his in his apartment this guy
was worth $3 mm-hmm he and he was
telling me the story of X Mike I kept
home you know you call somebody I don't
answer the phone you gotta go over there
knock on the door I'm like where's the
money from last night's man he paid me
me were always cool but every morning he
had a different story about what he did
how he got tied up in a Jacuzzi one time
and almost drowned that he picked up a
Chinese chick if it chick tied him up to
her a rubber doll I mean this guy had
out there like he was out there and what
was he like really good-looking you're
good-looking
southern accent Paul you know he
probably had a big dick if I had a guess
got a big dick ever since the fourth
North Carolina and he was [ __ ] a
walking right wow man blow - and he do
blow at night and when I'm gonna do blow
he really get funny and an accent would
come out and he was a Tar Heel all well
Carolina Yara yeah if you want to throw
fists talks no [ __ ] about the Tar Heels
he would throw some 15 and you know I
lived in South Carolina for long yeah
yeah they're the Gamecocks all those
people those people throw fists oh yeah
but this dude what was Tommy a star one
time how he [ __ ] somebody like guy
somebody big like somebody worth
millions of dollars like he was and he's
telling me this that she staying at this
hotel
that she loves that cocaine and all this
[ __ ] and he goes man you should have
seen she came here had just told to
throw your fur on the [ __ ] he goes
how far along was $80,000 Joey Diaz okay
Marley just I was wiping my dick I'll
even know how we got on poor car haul if
I feel is letting me know he lives in
Columbus if anybody gets to hold the car
Tom I was talking about him like sending
my love we had a great brother Vince who
was a fisherman and every day he would
go fishing in the Roaring Fork
[ __ ] river when I was a kid and he
called me in the [ __ ] room he knocked
I don't even have a phone and he [ __ ]
cooked me fish every night him and his
girlfriend Patty and she was chubby so
Carl will call her fatty I mean patty
nothing was fatty but you call a fatty
I'm gonna forget that hey fatty I mean
patty how you doing and she would say
[ __ ] you Carl
so what else is going on professor even
tell just don't say yeah that was just
interesting now for people who at home
in your 35 years old
uh-huh barbells towards kettlebells
uh-huh what's the big difference explain
to people at home listening a meal I
mean for me I feel like the kettle bell
is a more functional saying you could be
in a beef you could be in a bind and
have an hour to work out a day and
really do a great work out with a
35-pound kettlebell you know if you know
what you know what you're doing exactly
but the other hand you know I grew up on
weights I got up on a straight ball I
don't know about easy curl bar I don't
know about ISO press machine I had no
front had no bench Close Grip behind the
neck front of the neck bent over row one
arm pulls you take the bar yeah and you
stick on the corner any point of attack
yeah you take the two thing and you put
in the middle and you can make your own
t-bar all these people I had friends
that make kettle bell mouth kettle oh
yeah pull machines pull down so at what
age do you say you know what I don't
really want to do a conventional [ __ ]
workout no more I'm not for days I don't
have time to do my chest my shoulders
you know cause it's a pleasure
alright so pushes chest shoulders and
squat and then pull is it salt like
Jenson curls well just really I mean if
you do like traditional body body body
building a style training then you they
do like split routines and they'll do
chest and back one day right well I mean
you could do it mix it up any way you
want really there's no really set way
it's just really how you prefer to do it
chest back and triceps and then some
shoulder back shoulder straps straps and
[ __ ] butt bicep some people like to
train like that but six days but then
you get a kettlebell that's more
functional so I do ten sets of [ __ ]
swings in ten minutes and I've worked
basically every muscle group in my
[ __ ] body you worked a lot yeah but
you got a lot like still with the with
the kettlebell one of my principles that
I try to teach is that I try to we try
to push pull hinge squat lunge and and
all the workouts because those are the
movements that we do the most and
there's like a burpee [ __ ] yeah
yeah well don't do a burpee yeah yeah
there's ways you can modify I have like
a ton of different Burpee dirt
variations listen you're gonna make a
burpee hundred different ways when I
came out of prison I did so many burpees
in prison now what did you name the
football camp is where I discovered the
Burpee in the karaoke mm-hmm well you
have to move with your voice sideways
like before you did anything Joe Namath
football camp I was telling us somebody
out there by camps
Joe Namath he had done - I think Michael
Jordan basketball camp we're talking
about camp so I said Don I want the
Willis Reed basketball camp I went to a
bunch of camps I went to offense/defense
football camp that's Jack lamb but a
jackhammer are you kidding me if you
wanted to be a linebacker there was a
[ __ ] camp that taught you how to be
not only a line back about how to kill
people
yeah that position I went the five star
basketball camp but the best camp I ever
went to my life was Joe Namath football
camp and the reason behind it was that
it just wasn't for quarterbacks like a
lot of quarterbacks will not
but it was I like that they did
something that I had never done before
soon as you got to join a Miss football
camp you went to your room you know you
picked up your package you went to your
[ __ ] dorm you put your thing down and
you immediately went to your age group
well I was age group of what group they
were gonna put you in you know I hate to
9 my 13 13 to 16 I think I went when I
was like in the seventh grade the first
time the second time by the I got left
back that's why I said the first time
and how what doesn't the recommendation
of a friend of mine checking my brain
the first nade did it and fired Joe
Namath
football camp was after you put your
[ __ ] clothes down there was no food
there was nothing they made you report
to a circle and you had they tested you
on the 40 that's the first thing you did
Sunday morning [ __ ] you get that 9
o'clock first and you do the 40 bad no
stretch no nothing 40 ready boom boom
boom they give you two shots so you did
it you have to run back on line then you
did it again they and they took the best
speed and then you didn't know why but
from Monday morning to Saturday when you
left at 7 a.m. you got up at like 6:45
no breakfast no nothing and at 7 a.m.
you reported to a field that's how I had
in the game they work and he make you do
karaoke
uh-huh burpees and then they make you do
10 20 30 40 or 50 yards five of each
guys how old are you 12
Jesus Christ but this is what you do
this is what you do as a kid this is how
you learn to I've done football
conditioning man that's no joke and but
that's what they didn't let you they
didn't let you run sprints what they
made you do was move your hands to touch
your head and they want you to kick your
legs out kick it you know how hard that
is guys no friends do not publish
English pointing clear you do 25
push-ups in the seat and you have to do
it with a helmet on no shoulder pads a
helmet no pads just a helmet and you
have a get way kind of position don't
book and you have a start but
he made you like this with your hands go
back and forth right now I'm going all
the way down to my sides whatever leg
was extended it's the opposite hand but
he wanted your foot to be pointed that
was it and then you went right to the
doorman you ate whatever the [ __ ] you
want to eat french toast cereal apples
peaches whatever and then Friday they
took you back before you got on the bus
and they said let's do your 40 again and
you did your 40 again and you know that
99% of the people broke that time from
Sunday
yes the week yeah just stretching like
mum when I saw the Agostino girlfriend
before she before they got married I saw
her run one day and I had a stop
professor I had to stop what I was doing
and watch her run because her running
the form was perfect I had not seen that
in years I had a friend who ran
marathons I used to watch him run Hudson
County Park when I was a kid and his
form was breathless like when you see
somebody running that's why when you run
you can't run
you're like Bertrand the 26 mile right I
took my hat off to him I didn't torture
my the other guys I've made fun of him
or anything what pissed me off is that
he didn't go to a coach because just
three seconds or the coach just to teach
you little things man I mean you think
if I come to you and go professor I got
two weeks to fight John wick you know
say I got two weeks what what what is
the move we got three moves we got a
pass the guard I got a break his arm and
that's it we got three weeks to fight
John wick I don't know any jujitsu I
mean merit they take on a marathon
without training or anything even trains
I'm [ __ ] hard he told me the other
day that it took him on his body a month
yeah I believe it his body
it took him he was in pain as our
corpsman he was in pain he couldn't
sleep he had different problems
everything everything that you know at
the 14 mile mark he says people stop
falling apart
Oh 16 mile [ __ ] maybe I did a 10k once
and that [ __ ] was [ __ ] hard how long
is it ten c'mon six miles I think 6.6
miles it's taking like that something
like and now I was kind of training for
it my friends that were stationed at
Fort Bragg they wanted to do it then
they decided they weren't going to do it
so I stopped training and then the last
minute they decided do it again
we did it anyway after a night of
drinking that [ __ ] was [ __ ] the next
day I was toast man incorporate running
now um I do i do hiking because like I
quit yeah I hate when my dog so like
I'll do like not a full-on sprint uphill
but I'll do like 30-second one-minute
intervals of just one hour kind of run
at a brisk pace but not full on because
of my omni yeah he directed that right
to you too many the projected that is a
clean these are clean he's got those
[ __ ] like those fish those cheese for
your classroom to lose awaiting fish
stop in the past out here one day show
you see best nice chub no it's wait
watch watches can we talk about adding
some points to these fish options
because he's using for the free points
no if I told you could eat bananas all
day and not gain a pound you gave me
bananas on that if you drink a banana
you're gonna [ __ ] gain a lot of weight
do you eat the banana you'd be fine
you could eat 10 bananas and be fine and
just pop little farts I definitely had
bright sadness after I took the sixth
floor I took the 7:40 a.m. this morning
and I took a dump before I got on the
plane yeah I'm trying out for the night
before nice and I sat next to this lady
on the place was a little chubby cute
and there was a skinny girl that was in
the window the whole plane was back it
was just me the skinny chick in the
[ __ ] back of the plane cuz when you
get the Burbank you get the board from
the bank of a plane huh
so this girl's like that long legs is
she sitting there like a no she got that
man I don't give a [ __ ] I had put my
headphones on but 20 minutes in route I
blasted one of them oh yeah that was
warm and they all started staring at the
chubby chick way cool
I'm saying I play it like I believe you
smell it you passed a buckle she knew
people looking at it she could Falls
people look at that poor soul oh my god
he's very sweet we talked at the EMA
Haven said did you smell that
oh my god that was awful you probably
eat seafood everything that everyday in
Vegas oh no I hate Turkey her had the
roast turkey nope that's not Turkey no
my words I don't know the turkey
sandwich this is the reason why I go to
the South Point I can't light it cuz I
go back to my room 9:30 called the time
and I get room service if they bring me
an open-faced turkey sandwich America
doesn't even know what those are anymore
yeah yeah it's two Peters white people
for this is a white bread with white
meat turkey on top yeah got a little
side of stuff a little side of mashed
potatoes no I know it though and it's
ring containers a [ __ ] cranberry
sauce and pumpkin gravy on the side I
don't mean I don't touch anything else I
just take a little bit of the gravy salt
and pepper
I just eat the [ __ ] white bread the
turkey like a savage know we've been
mashed potatoes of the stuff that
reminds me of a sandwich that I used to
get at this place called lovebirds it
was like the Thanksgiving turkey
sandwich I loved it
that's all it was like Thanksgiving on
oh yeah very sausage stuffing and oh my
god I loved her I [ __ ] loved her but
it's gotta be perfect turkey like I want
somewhere a couple of months ago the
turkey tastes like it was [ __ ]
Thanksgiving it was [ __ ] June they
started tell you from [ __ ]
Thanksgiving [ __ ] [ __ ] I like my
turkey fresh [ __ ] pres professor how
lonely why did you stumble upon
kettlebells what made you same thing you
just were like no like what happened was
like this is when I owned a gym and saw
in Highland Park and you know when you
know what the [ __ ] were doing man and uh
I had this business partner bill and he
was a good business partner he's always
trying to figure out different things to
do and he's like hey why don't we get a
kettlebell instructor and I was like I
was like you know I've heard good things
about I heard it's good for martial arts
but I have no idea what to do so I was
like yeah let's check it out let's try
it you know so then we uh he did the
research and he found a certified
instructor he started teaching he taught
like the basics you know
and like you know back then nobody
really did anything outside of the basic
screaming I think nobody really did
anything and I was like man I really
like this kettlebell stuff but they just
do the same [ __ ] over and over and over
and people weren't coming to the
bootcamp anymore you know my back was
jacked up and then after a while it's
like you know what man like I started
that's when I started experimenting
Ashley man like oh when I first started
developing kettle Jitsu I was sitting in
the back I used to live in the back of
my gym man I want a [ __ ] nightmare
with my crazy ass dog and girlfriend -
oh my god anyway I was I was stoned and
then I was like you know what nothing
but you could do jujitsu moves with the
kettle ball so I just would open my door
jump on the mat grab a kettlebell and I
started doing like hip escapes and
rocking chairs like I wasn't wow and
then that's when I just opened up
Pandora's box and I just started
experimenting started developing all
kinds of other [ __ ] you know swings from
a fighting stance throwing punches with
kettlebells kettlebells flows all this
stuff you know like nobody had ever
really done that before and um then I
stumbled upon a guy named Mark de Grasse
he's the one who actually started the on
on it Academy and he was he had a
website who's selling some kettlebells
and he has pretty cool videos he was
thinking outside of the box but not like
me but I liked what he was doing so I
went there to buy some kettlebells and
to network you know so I got the
kettlebells I'll say hey man I want to
show you this stuff that I've been
developing called Kido Jitsu just to see
what you think you know and I started
doing some flows and and stuff and he's
this was like he's like hey Matt can i
film this and he sort of filming it and
then he like dude we need to do a DVD
and then I was like really yeah you want
to do a deep I was like cool man so
that's that's when it when it all
started after I did that first DVD it's
sold in like 30 countries worldwide and
some people embrace it and were like
cool finally something new the couple
and those the the traditionalists were
like yeah you're not supposed to do that
with a kid Oh bill you're gonna hurt
people blah blah blah blah blah and then
like I had I was like kind of new to the
fitness interview so I didn't know how
things work but since people were buying
the DVD people started asking to get
certified by it I was like a would or
he's like my business partner mark was
like yeah man
gonna want to get certified I was like
wow that's crazy so I started having
certifications and people flying out
from around the world to come out and
get certified and fly me to like Italy
and stuff like that which is treating
dope man I mean it's pretty cool man
it's very it's humbling and flattering
now if your workout is how long how much
how much time is involved with
kettlebells
like this is what we do and that's a
that's a misconception people don't
realize that like with me body weight
and kettlebell are equal like you should
I really feel like you should master
your body it's your body you know that's
what martial arts is is mastery of your
body you know martial arts it is
movement you know so you should know how
to do forward and backward rolls and
burpees and all kind of stuff like that
you know to establish that mind-body
connection you know plus the way I teach
it's imperative to warm up with the body
weight only with no resistance at all
get your joints ready to get your core
firing and everything before you pick up
that kettlebell start swinging it around
people and they're that way it prevents
injury so in my classes we do 30 minutes
of bodyweight 30 minutes of kettlebell
an hour of kettlebell would be [ __ ]
really yeah it would be [ __ ] real so
the thing is we start off with mobility
then we do a little core work then we do
an ab workout then we do a bodyweight
workout and then it's time for the
kettlebell warm-up and do we do a
kettlebell warm-up we do intervals and
then we'll turn it into maybe a flow or
a pyramid for the end of the workout so
when I watch you on Facebook live that's
the end of the class is to come on the
last bit of the class right there most
of the time if it's the body weight
that's like probably like our main body
weight workout and if you see the
kettlebell workout that's probably like
the last two minutes of the how many
days a week do you go live at
five-thirty with the kettlebell track
it's Monday Wednesday Friday at 5:30
a.m. so that's like usually I'll post
like that workout right after that and
then I teach in the evenings and on
Saturdays as well well I can't thank you
but the biggest thing was in the morning
was that [ __ ] dude that just died
what's - dude then meant the blender
what's the adventure blender why he made
the blender to that he became [ __ ]
rich off he just died a couple years ago
it was nine he kept the whole country
fed in the 50s he would come on at 9:00
in the morning and you did jumping jacks
Jack LaLanne Jack LaLanne yeah
blames a [ __ ] man when did he make it
into big he admitted the juicer or
something he may have invented he did
yeah yeah because I really like he used
to do the commercials but way ahead of
his juicer juicer yeah yeah he's awesome
man he was [ __ ] but I have a coming
from Pioneer the black and white my mom
used to work at Jack LaLanne she says
she's do I mean trained at Jack LaLanne
Jim over here my mommy said tell me that
Jack boy in health spa yeah yeah that
came out wrong but when I first started
watching Jack was my anymore and I
remember like after about a month I
would get up to do what he was doing
mm-hmm you know in those days there
wasn't no [ __ ] kettlebells he was not
doing this with his own he was doing a
lot he looks great
he was awesome he would wear like a
tight little body shame that nobody
exactly buddy was old even then he was
or yeah you know in 1966 gotta be
30-something fool he's probably like one
of like the first like fitness stars you
know I'm saying like he was a fitness
star back then there were no Athena
stars back then he was a pioneer man
chuckling he invaded he invented the
juicer like he was the first nose
putting carrots and olives and [ __ ]
spinach mark man man people you like
well he was serving it how they figured
out people yeah that know how to do the
combinations and stuff like that yeah
Jack LaLanne would just make carried
drinking [ __ ] be going wrong in there
used to tell me like a juice of ham
doughnut some kale but let's can you
imagine if you like make kale juice for
people and we're pineapple whatever
concoction but you drew something in
knowing that having like something it is
great tossed it don't up nothing a
glazed doughnut in there like I can't
believe there's not sure about Cuba in
the back come what you doing there
[ __ ] tablespoons and they're sitting
at home like I'm not little why am I not
losing away here I've been working out
I've been eating all these juices yeah
that's [ __ ] crazy if they cheat if
they're made you I always think about
that like that's what we know Weight
Watchers really they're not against you
eating up but then they want you to ask
creepy questions at a restaurant which I
will ask creepy questions yeah I got I
won't ask away their shoes I got it here
excuse me what you would how does the
fish get fried eating out with people
this happen leafless before we give me
pet tap for the four iced teas I'm out
of here
this guy just embarrassed me to bugger
then what you know they want you to ask
creepy questions and was it cooked in
has a fried well yeah do you know much
fat isn't there if he puts butter this
is it wind or is it whatever creepy
piano
let's [ __ ] Gentiles I hate annoying
waiters yeah you know cuz I'm gonna spit
my [ __ ] food yeah I'm saying I would
if you tortured me and that was a way
that I'd spit your [ __ ] song man
that's the webslinger smell yeah I'd
fling a slant your pork fried rice that
you'd be thinking well this [ __ ] ham
is delicious
you beat the [ __ ] that's not that with I
swear to God yeah they drive me crazy
and you know like little things which I
don't so I just keep everything like
them it's weird like if you eat a piece
of sea bass it's zero [ __ ] point but
I get that same sea bass out what's the
[ __ ] place in Burbank what I love and
I was going in there for a long time you
can see passing oh wow this is great
Oh Morton's know what's the [ __ ]
Chinese place to chain oh wait the
Peking you've changed yep chef Chang's
you have any points the sea bass is @p
of change 21 for the dollar they toss
all kinds of butter and that's all
that's why that's right why it tastes so
good
sugar and pork right you know like we
have a friend that one no sugar diet hmm
and he lost the [ __ ] way yeah I know
I have a student that did that I have
seniors it's amazing it's but the
problem is this sugar and everything
professor yeah yeah but you know like if
you just cut out like sugary drinks
I mean like in general dude like it
makes a huge difference to you don't
realize how much sugar you're eating you
know I was talking to Brian makes a huge
difference
I was talking to bread the guy who runs
a subconscious and he was saying he gets
like a lot of Thai food but he even when
he orders he has to ask them to put like
no sugar on the sauce yeah yeah yeah
yeah some of those sauces in Thai food
or yeah yeah we're trying to see that
that's crazy
yeah Chinese food - yeah hell yeah they
put some sugar oh no no no all those oh
you gotta like white boy sauce yeah
that's why I love you that's what you're
saying is like that they don't really
encourage you to eat out whenever you're
on weight loss or eat or a squid be
questioned if you come to my restaurant
say don't punch ugh on my thigh yeah
yeah I'll put more [ __ ] sugar than
your block I'll put sativa what's that
what's that sugar that tastes like sugar
yeah Stevie sativa
I'll call Steve you you're the data
front no I'm scared oh that and that's
what you know it's it's it's you
everything changes after 40 like I have
it all a dot for last three months I've
been living it now
hmm I didn't know what it was I don't
I'd stomach cancer guys oh man I had to
stop chewing nicotine gum I changed
every day I stopped eating weird stuff I
didn't know what it was I even stopped
at a most on one yeah about a month ago
you have and then you say well the
edibles I have a stop because of the
appetite you can't listen there's
another dietician that could deal with
edibles
this self-control is know something did
I did I get [ __ ] I do really rephrase
he's got no nor much that stole the
munchies see that's the difference I
could smoke pot to the pigeons come home
uh-huh and have an apple and I'm good no
yeah I have two green apples there's a
difference a banana and I'm good but
edibles when we eat those cheaper
choosers expired one who eat less
wastage dog I went home one day and they
like 10 days ago and I just destroyed
that like two sandwiches yeah cold-cut
that's what this is but this is after 20
minutes of eating healthy food I just
don't go home and make a [ __ ] salami
sandwich yeah yeah I go home and have an
apple then I have another apple and I
have a Weight Watchers 2.7 gram protein
bar
that I have another one I drink a bunch
of water and if after that I'm still
having a hard time then I just draw the
talent I go what am I gonna do I can't
control myself I got to eat this - yeah
I had to go deep and that's what I do
well I can't I couldn't control the
edible one she at night and every minute
after 11 o'clock like we'd sit here like
let's say we get high at 7:30 the
podcast ends at 10:00 we sit here
talking till 11:00 and the whole time
I'm thinking about what I'm gonna [ __ ] I
don't have the balls to go to Denny's at
night like that that's the only thing
that saves me I won't go to Denny's I
won't go to 7-eleven I won't eat chips
I don't do nothing like that if I do all
you know what else are we I have a
before I bet I have a protein shake yeah
I'm approaching [ __ ] I have a coconut
you run the blender like to the wall I
don't give a Frenchman's [ __ ] they can't
hear me to beat the star munchies is
just don't keep anything bad in your
you're picking your pad you know well
then you leave the house but then you
leave the house you're edible I'm number
one the hot sauce at all I live a
hundred yards from one of the worst
places the world has been for me it
would be destructive and one way namely
one in there have one in the morning I'm
building what I gave friend Eric yeah
how many store have we killed it in
other places
yum yum dog all right he'll open 24
hours [ __ ] that
and then Mexicans which means they look
at you they don't give you food by the
on-state look at you and go hmm
hmm so um how you going then get a bagel
sandwich get the coconut [ __ ] on ice
right which is a thousand calories along
oh my god and then get two doughnuts is
sitting then get a cup of coffee and sit
there [ __ ] right joke but I'm always
scared that somebody's gonna come off
the 101 and rob the joint I'm gonna be
in the Hat that's why I don't go in
there I'm like [ __ ] Doug Denny's oh
why would they rob you do you know the
mind of an addict don't mind Robin go
rob the doughnuts shut across the street
from the the gym one day huh
I got 5:30 in the morning we heard we
heard some ruckus over there and later
on we they held the place up at gum
point later on we're like Oh although
place in the late night now and only I
would never want to be at that Denny's
when the [ __ ] goes off one night and
it's gonna go off
no go to that Betty's at 1:00 in the
morning and that's some crazy [ __ ] over
that daddy's right there like some Pulp
Fiction [ __ ] when the head it's crazy
[ __ ] over there I think it's crazy
listen I moved no home when I moved up
here there were hookers on pure straight
up hookers he got it he got attacked by
one one night I kept thinking they're
going bro got attacked by a prostitute
and she she hang it's a long story she's
on her phone except bandages I abandoned
it at the blackjack table you know I've
been going out my mom had a bog rolled
up tribal doubt since I was a kid I used
to go on then I didn't have a curfew you
know something my wife this that I'm
sick of going on it mmm
like I really am at this age like I'm
man I have a kid I'm sick of it you know
right home with Danny goes you know my
oldest daughter always ask me Dad are
you going out he goes yeah I'm going out
but I'm just gonna do a set and I'm
coming right home with it the older
daughter goes no no no what am I just
staying at home you know what that's why
I'm like that for a long time I was at
war myself professor you have to go out
at night and now I can't do it no yeah I
can't do it tomorrow I got a meeting at
8:00 tomorrow my date does that stop
810 32 and then have a CIFOR I got a
6:30 tomorrow night tomorrow never
[ __ ] ends get along Daniel tomorrow's
a long [ __ ] day tomorrow it's all
white people and talking and you know
[ __ ] and [ __ ] all it starts
tomorrow
mmm like whatever I've gone through all
year is nothing till now then Wednesday
I go back down every three the Wilshire
Boulevard I got a hell of a [ __ ] week
this week you know I can't I can't do
that no more like I used to like eight
tomorrow's meetings at 8:00 I'm over
that [ __ ] too many I'm almost I'm
pushing 50 men so like I don't like
going out and hanging on bars and [ __ ]
like that no and then the next day after
teach class [ __ ] that it's so weird how
many years I remember when I was younger
people would say you're gonna see that
your Knights are gonna get oh uh if I
stay out till 2 now and get up at 8 the
next day thump your heart with your [ __ ]
yeah never mind having a drink I don't
know how people go out during the week
and have like four [ __ ] drinks oh I
can't do this
that's great but you could get dirty no
dude are you [ __ ] Christ Christ I
could but I haven't drink in a while and
I drank on Friday night I was up the
Atomics had two drinks and I burped on
purpose but I got the next morning I
felt like a little like I was almost
sick a little bit like I had two other
kind of strong drinks but go together I
was drinking a [ __ ] bar Jesus and
leaving empty bottles everywhere I don't
like drinking I've never like this what
do you like like smoking weed and eating
fish I eat too much have you ever woken
up so like let's say you go home right
you eat any go to bed have you ever
woken up only four or five and him a
little snack and then went back to bed
oh my god the other I got a little they
know what they got a glass of water my
friend left the lobster crab she left a
lobster yeah what's that sandwich they
made those stairs at the stop point
though lobster grilled cheese Oh mom you
know I got up at 5:00 in the morning to
get water and I open up oh my god what
is that that's a lot I took that piece
of bread off and just ate the lobster
meat like a savage in and through the
bread and cheese away we're right back
to that lobster breath I woke up that
sleep apnea mask not like [ __ ]
lobster dad write down with [ __ ]
imbecile
haha my god I usually brush my teeth and
Listerine and then go to bed I got up in
the middle of life though I went to get
one and I was still stoned yeah like
sometimes from the edible you get up in
the middle night oh my god Jack did you
[ __ ] me up with some [ __ ] you gave me
one time man oh yeah like the one time
like well I learned my lesson cuz like I
I think was on Christmas or something
he's like Merry Christmas professor he
has me a [ __ ] and blow full of stars
and I've never had I didn't I never ate
one of those started before I shouldn't
I ate a full one and I woke up and I was
still [ __ ] high man I was like what
the [ __ ] and I had a I had to go teach
class at 5:30 later all they show with
the [ __ ] man what's up with that [ __ ]
star he's like oh I forgot to tell you
just to eat half a some different things
so strong man oh my god nothing worse
than waking up and still being alive Oh
master easy I've never experienced that
with the edibles but I do whatever I'd
love like I like if I sleep then I wake
up and I'm usually like good but I woke
up and I was [ __ ] there's three days
a week then I wake up in the mornings I
like look I catch myself just staring at
the clock got a nice nice cooperation so
there's no more drama
yeah I have no reason to lie to anybody
they're more as I get up I walked
imagine I like to catch myself staring
at the coffee and then I put the cup in
when I press it before you even start
the coffee before you take you to make a
cup of coffee in the morning 15 it's
just it takes three minutes to push the
button there's some mornings I get up
and I just I don't even know where to
start
I can't even know what it's done you
people think I'm a little bit like Oh
Jodie's is tolerance Joey Diaz pays for
that [ __ ] morning some mornings I wake
up you wake up on the road you know
where the [ __ ] you are like you know
what you wake up you feel like Martin
Sheen the apocalypse definitely woke up
in the hotel room he didn't know where
he was I gone who can there's some
mornings I wake up oh no
my god it's like something like I don't
know over [ __ ] like I wake up some
mornings I don't know what my schedule
is so I look at it even though I went
over it before I went to bed like I get
up some mornings and I'm either a
professor so I go into the kitchen the
cats are me out like the hallway look at
the coffee machine for a little while
and I'll pop it in can i press the
button and what's coming out I run to
the bathroom when I pee
and I hope I don't my computer and I
press the button to get the computer
going then I run back into the kitchen I
pushed stevia in the coffee my sterotype
broke they're like Cuban style like I
mean like you must stop yeah and if I
drink that first cup of coffee and I'm
still at Morris then I have another one
mmm but if I don't if that cup of coffee
that cup of coffee usually should
deviate the hive name before yeah then I
wait a couple minutes and take another
Pete maybe that pushes piece of poop out
of my muffler and that's when I smoke
the first master that's how I start my
yeah wow if that coffee if that who
comes to coffee don't overcome too high
I don't get I I wait I wait it out I
know in my heart that whatever my plans
are
I gotta include a workout man tonight
because the only way I'm gonna get this
TAC out of my bodies if I sweat it out
drink it out so sometimes I say [ __ ] it
I don't have till 12 o'clock to do
jujitsu or nothing
I go my yard is just selling the
kettlebells like an animal start hitting
the bag and I'll [ __ ] smell it once I
smell it coming out of me you smell the
oh I smell yours annex I can smell
everything the alcohol all the [ __ ]
ice no everything coming out of my
[ __ ] anxiety medication I'll even
know if it's a I don't know what they
give me whatever the little white pills
they give me but I can smell like the
top Correa's no guys come on come on
Isis being on this how much [ __ ] weed
do we [ __ ] it dude I was just telling me
I was like I need a weed sponsor because
it's like a regular bill of mine now
it's not even the weight as what we were
doing a year ago like two years ago
like hello if we got high on Monday and
Wednesday on Thursday well you guys eat
a lot you might add a little [ __ ] who
not anymore
they're like the first time I came on
the show I was just like you guys are
poppin that [ __ ] like it was listen I
was loving sod cast a lot of those
podcast it makes them they're
entertaining this [ __ ] for degree
because there's nobody here that's
whatever like nobody would be every if
three people are high what kind of
conversation is that that's not a
[ __ ] conversation that's just you
know yeah yeah a giggle desk but you
gotta figure drop whenever I go to a
weed store like when I go to a science a
terrible every time I walk is so
terrible they told me sometime Adam the
latest like sunset what herb or I go is
rattled me around the caller so whenever
I go with them a guy always pulled me
aside and goes bro
try this this is what's killing
[ __ ] like this time jellies I
have shot the shouts don't come on hold
on before you leave I have something for
you he'll give me some we're all like
Armenians
yeah and believe Tommy and Joey I've
never smoked weed like that and I don't
hear what some [ __ ] he gives me some
[ __ ] that's rocket fuel when I choose
Armenia did he give you that uh hash
[ __ ] no no that's the one I jus look at
look at the container that's the one
oxygen yeah you don't know names you
know I'm saying just call the one you
don't want his name up there I donate me
the whole yet guy is it the three month
you don't know nothing obscene one
monkey covers his eyes or monkey cuz
that's the official post of the church
what's happening now Meeta oh yeah a guy
yeah you don't know nothing I don't know
nothing I don't know some guy come they
drop it off
don't you pay for you I don't know what
I give how much is it huh oh I like that
Matt because you know they don't really
make hash anymore no that's a that's a
Swedish type that's a [ __ ] that's
something dipped in something tell me
wasn't actually a hash but it reminds me
it has ya know it's got that has she
stay still don't like her and the
texture the texture as well that's good
that you at least even does do you do
any CBD products I do some of the CBD
vapes and stuff like that does it help
you without like for me
for me it relaxes me you know well yeah
man like like yeah the thing is is you
have to know how to rest you men and you
know like I really got my personal diet
on track as well too so like I eat
totally different now man don't you mean
eat any animal products anymore so I'm
just waiting so let you say hey little
products what do you mean professor
anything that has anything from an
animal like milk cheese meat none of
that anymore so what's your typical diet
so like you know what I just lose it
killing you Lee that's at that Chilean
seabass
[Laughter]
hazing going on over here and get all
those walls [ __ ] farmers what's your
typical breakfast
I don't eat nothing you go to that
[ __ ] gym into those kettlebells and
London your stuff no man like I
integrate it fast
that's another thing that is like
internet if I was like Joe Rogan talks
about it
because like when I wake up in the
morning I have a shot a shot of espresso
and makes me use the bathroom and I
drink water with lemon and man it makes
me feel full but like when you workout
on an empty stomach like that you burn a
lot more fat as well it's one of those
like slow creepers out is not my [ __ ] is
this is whey protein whey protein I
should've killed you
whey protein mixed with milk you know
you mix it with love with water
oh my god I'm a couple way like that
organic I get that organic pure protein
and then I that on it then just sent me
the Mexican chocolates clean by yeah
that [ __ ] is clean I like to hit some
more water [ __ ] it nice and some ice
cubes it's [ __ ] perfect so unless you
but right alright so now what do you eat
for lunch out that door professor if you
don't mind before lead thighs just for
two minutes
yes trust me it's my fart and I'm almost
dying over there myself it's tremendous
I probably have my first meal around
noon but like over this last like 8
months that I've stopped eating animal
products I uh I've been kind of like
learning how to cook and [ __ ] you know
so I eat like a lot of beans rice I eat
like a lot of vegan Mexican food now but
I just don't um what do you put me rice
you brown rice or white rice um like
just like Mexican rice you know stuff
like that like what kind of mix it what
are you put in the Mexican wine well
like ice a [ __ ] you know you look on
wait why do they the worst thing but
yeah yeah yeah rice I'd like actually
like like the last month I've been not
not eating that many cars so so like my
like I'll have like a like a taco with
like some soy meat but I'll just make it
like a tiger I'll put Pico the guy on it
likes like so you're a vegan right now
pretty much pretty much like I wasn't at
first like I said out the meat but the
cheese man that shit's looking how to
hold on me for a minute you know and
then but now so many companies are
investing in and they're making better
like vegan cheese's and stuff like now
so like they have all the stuff that I
can cook with to make like good like
good vegan food what's a vegan cheese or
you recommend um you see kite Hill
there's a company called kite Hill how
do you spell Hill kite Hill yeah they
have like good like cream cheese they
also have like really good non-dairy
yogurts and stuff like that oh my god
would be like let's say you won't make a
sandwich huh let's say I want to make
they even have like vegan deli meats and
[ __ ] like that too many yeah any just
about anything you you can possibly
imagine they took and have it like no
vegan subway sandwich is really good
though I mean that's like [ __ ] oh man
that's some bad [ __ ] right there
yeah that's really all that [ __ ] a lot a
lot of people don't realize like deli
meats processed meats bake and all that
[ __ ] that's just like a like is
literally labeled as a carcinogen by the
World Health Organization and a bunch of
them cut down yeah was like one of the
things I have cut down on but I can't
believe uh-huh I cannot boo here it's
bacon yeah yeah that's good know what I
mean like you know everything in
moderation but I don't mind like this
week I had I had a Friday from God
another Saturday morning they had a
breakfast this morning had a protein
shake but sad they had breakfast in the
room I had two pieces of bacon yeah if
they give me three I need two only two
pieces cuz it's four points you know I'm
pretty good with that so eggs are free
uh-huh I can eat six eggs for breakfast
they're free Jack so I don't ex widow
tortilla with salsa and black beans I'm
only paying for the [ __ ] for the
tortilla mm-hmm the salsa
yeah beans man I have a whole different
appreciation for being beans are
delicious but like beans that have like
a shitload of protein plus they have
like fiber and other vitamins and stuff
in it like something that meat doesn't
really have meat doesn't have fiber but
like you know we always look at beans
it's like a side dish but man like you
know I've been doing all this research
and stuff since I stopped eating meat
and there's like these blue zones where
people live the longest you know they
have like five of them and there's one
in Costa Rica and Italy Loma Linda
California because the seventh-day
adventists they don't eat meat stuff
there's like a lot of vegetarians and
they live the longest out of anybody in
the world so uh but all of them eat
beans that's something they have in
common so they like there's doctors I
say like if you eat a cup of beans a day
it expends it it'll extend your life for
four years because they're just so good
for you man you know but we always look
at them as like a side dish or something
like that but in Costa Rica one of the
blue zones these people they live off of
beans rice and corn tortillas but they
just make it all themselves [ __ ] and
these people live to like over a hundred
what's a boozer blue zone is this guy
Dan rettner I think his name is in in
collaboration with the National
Geographic they studied all different
regions all over the world to see where
people live the longest you know so they
they they they narrowed it down to blue
zones because like on that they had a
map and they narrowed it down and ate
with a blue marker they just marked all
these the places you know so they just
started calling the blue zones so in
these places they have the highest
concentration of sentence sentence means
people who live past 100 but it was
Oakland Oakland Lu is one of the blue
zones
Okinawa is one of the blue because of
the efficient change yeah but now but
now they're they're like they days to be
the number one
but what happened is is because Japanese
has a big Western influence now they're
getting fast food in Okinawa so they
used to be the best but now Loma Linda
is the number one place where the people
live the longest
so the those are the Blue Zone there's a
place on I think it's Sardinia Italy
there's a place in Greece Costa Rica and
Lamba Linda California let's get
something out of the way if I could
leave black beans and rice Cuban yeah I
mean dude fried bananas every day that's
a good meal man I would eat that every
day you could dance right I could live
I'll learn four ounces of fried bananas
isn't that bad food not about do they
put me in the beans no no like Cuban
black beans no do you in Cuban black
beans and rice and plantains mr. [ __ ]
delicious with the raw onion and you get
the grater
yeah and you put it over the [ __ ]
white rice and a black man we taste a
nicer place in Boca
but I dream of every day was called the
harvest restaurant it was just a vegan
restaurant the only thing that they
served only meat that they had was
chicken they had a certain type of
chicken but that was it they had been
tearing the spot show they had yeah but
this is I used to go there my credit
card like I was addicted to this
restaurant my day what did you get my
best breakfast ever
they had it was called Swiss granola it
was a black in today's standards a
thousand calories but it didn't matter
for me it was way better than eating
eggs for breakfast and I used to be a
runner that had just come out of the jab
just come out of prison so I used to be
in the halfway house I used to go to the
harvest way before I went to a halfway
house there tea you know how people say
to you oh my god caffeine listen listen
to me guys I could drink a Red Bull and
pass out they had a team professor a
regular tea that they gave you like when
you went there they said to do you want
the house tea or jasmine and those day
and we had the boulder his way what's
that big company so that celestial
Seasonings okay yeah cheese yeah almost
easy company came out a boulder dogs
let's the Ephesian was in Boulder they
have a tea look it up it's called lemon
something hmm
still celestial Seasonings has a tea and
it's called so lemon something guys I
was there
lemons Inca oh my god
I was hooked well then it was a lot of
caffeine in it I don't know at that time
I was into cocaine I was at the
cocaine's a hell of a drug in Haiti you
know after I got locked up you remember
what Boulder was in 84 it was the
perfect match for me when I got there an
85 Boulder was a place that when you
looked at activities it didn't have like
this dad they had like moonlight hikes
you know you know what activity wasn't
Boulder huh getting together and [ __ ]
dancing till midnight how's your
caffeine zero caffeine not a little bit
the tea is delicious
I got addicted to the flavor at the time
but they had a house blend there oh it
was the only tea professor you ever take
a black beauty
no what is that a black beauty's a diet
pill in the 70s it's what Liberace was
giving that David which one what
Liberace oh it's on HBO movie Michael
Douglas pays Liberace but in the
seventies a big thing tonight was
Douglas yes the bride she's [ __ ]
tremendous why is it good is it worth
watching
yes take a break Jason bored second is
the end of the [ __ ] world
that's my gals part of his training but
uh black beauties with these little
black things and they gave you doctors
prescribing to you to get you on by it's
like they were you know exit trim why
what's this [ __ ] when you own the
pharmacies now let me tell you something
you go follow anybody I diet medication
those pills you take over the counter
that's just legal speed yeah hey man
[ __ ] my day they used to give you black
beauties we stopped them
and snoring oh my god and you feel you I
move it to its back when you snore the
Black Beauty I would shift out oh my god
oh my god
I would drink black beauties how many
black beauties drink sambuca I was
getting I was getting black oh my god I
[ __ ] up with manic this Morgan's out
that's cuties what is that something
it's a horse it's like a little cord
don't you 25 it's the great look or it's
a book up yes I'm Lucas I'm good no
Italian
it's like [ __ ] it doesn't get you
drunk oh it's got a million [ __ ]
calories in sugar but I'm gonna forget
one that you're gonna bottle that we all
eat those black beauties I was sick for
a [ __ ] I got outside of beauty oh
we're talking about the diet pills and
all the original music no I know that
you're not then they have blues or
something you know I don't remember was
not a diet the [ __ ] seventies but in
79 80 I used to go to East Stroudsburg
Pennsylvania to get drugs more than one
of my big sales was black beauties these
little speedos because the wrestlers
were using to cut weight would you snort
them though that you could slaughter you
could eat them oh my it's not everything
I wasn't much of a snorter you start the
next four so it's eSATA but I could
never do like the day those diet pills
would make you jittery yeah they were
big in the seventies and eighties people
went off the deep end you know that's
why kills me when people like wow the
opioid problem with ASM we've had a
problem in this country since 1970
[ __ ] nine with drugs like we in this
country was what they thought was a
problem was never a problem
when when the hippies were around who
were hippies Marvin they were doing acid
and they were smoking pot they weren't
bothering nobody
then acid don't make you rock it's a
dollar ahead hmm two dollars an acid
don't make you rob we got hit with
leopard emic in 1979 after they were
protesting no shepper [ __ ] up protest we
will epidemic
since 1979 that the addiction just keeps
rolling off into other
oh yeah man people get along no no the
first epidemic that we got killed it was
a drug named cocaine hmm and then it's
never stops instead and see the MDMA
we're always reinventing that crack then
heroin came back after 9/11 and now the
opioid problem is back it's never
[ __ ] stop like you know my friend
what am i Tyler's friend in the world
that his kid is in a rehab for the ninth
time he's 20 years old and he my friend
calls me you know we had the same
problem over 20 was just coke we just
didn't even know it we didn't know it
that we were gonna fall into this
[ __ ] crisis since there's been a
crisis in this country for 30 40 [ __ ]
years forty five years has been a crisis
in this [ __ ] company there's no war
on drugs that's propaganda for white
people to buy into that's been a war on
drug his his [ __ ] 1982 when the
government realized how much money there
wasn't cocaine that was the end of the
war how much he's a little chubby
Mexican with the belt buckle maker he's
in Forbes magazine he's a little chubby
Mexican with a belt buckle that [ __ ]
as a horse's name he has a horse you
know he ran out of heat one night sweet
burnt a million dollars cash I don't
burn the clean all the bill my wife
could die of [ __ ] freezing before I
burn at 20 hmm and this guy live a
million dollars on [ __ ] fire that's
when the epidemic [ __ ] started in
this country there's no opioid epidemic
this is the same epidemic of addiction
that has been rolling over in this
country for the last 40 [ __ ] years
yeah I miss Tony better that [ __ ]
we get some shoutouts real quick number
one I had a really [ __ ] great time in
Vegas and I want to thank Serena and
Tony they came down they brought me
music what you're gonna install they
brought a present for my daughter I mean
they were just great people in Vegas and
we can Frederick Bach Bach calm you know
Randy volara
Christina weeks miss fizzle Nancy
Jimenez Adrienne were crevalle Evan
Patrick Ronny be Richard Hernandez and
disposable alien brains I love all you
[ __ ] you know I'm saying you
know I love you guys with all my heart
you guys come to the shows and you're
like you know what man you helped me a
lot that's what you guys keep me in
[ __ ] check
you guys make me a better [ __ ] man so
I thank you guys don't forget you ties
sold out we added an extra show on
Thursday night in Salt Lake City and
wise guys but there's a few tickets left
so if you don't jump on them that'll be
gonna no come Graham not adding another
show I'm too old to do [ __ ] six shows
[ __ ] and then we got [ __ ] the
Kansas City improv [ __ ] August 9th
through the 11th sharpen your [ __ ]
dicks uncle joey's common straight-up
humility I don't give a [ __ ] you know
your how old are you and Bruce Lee died
do you remember anything about Bruce Lee
I think he was already dead by the time
I realized who he was it's so funny when
Bruce Lee died the first thing that
happened when did he die Bruce Lee died
July of 73 we should be coming up on his
anniversary how was that like two years
old his anniversary should be maybe
Wednesday if I'm correct when it's Bruce
Lee's date of birth date of death god
bless his soul yeah he was the man The
Godfather of MMA oh he's down on my
birthday July 20th there you go you
[ __ ] kiss adapted say you were born
I'm Bruce Lee's birthday it should make
your identify some but crazy if you look
at the Dragon was released like seven
days before he died Seaver but the
release day an event for the drag of
this this is the creepy [ __ ] about this
like hee-hee Enter the Dragon came out
and he died either a week before or we
go I didn't know that and it would have
not be in America because they're saying
America got released on the 19th of
August like a month later and what about
no I think it was a little earlier but
this movie he died that's what gave the
movie even more popularity I mean once
he died the movie was in the movie
theaters and I just [ __ ] him anyway it's
just [ __ ] nuts naturally you know
yeah but it's crazy when Bruce Lee first
died like III went to Chinatown I bought
everything I could you know I got the
tower jeet kune do-- I read everything
and I was really sold on it but then
something really weird happened the fast
people started bogarting [ __ ] people
would have like one scene of Bruce Lee
throwing the kick and they'd get another
guy and put a black suit on him and then
around that whole movie with Bruce Lee
with three e's or li or Bruce with as he
it was [ __ ] non-stop man I felt so bad
after a while I couldn't watch anything
anymore I think Game of Death is one of
the worst pieces of [ __ ] now that's
never been made in my life ever and you
know what it wasn't to be released like
yeah I wasn't it just was not to be
released if you would have gone to Bruce
Lee and said Bruce should we release his
here we're gonna no just give it to my
kids let them see what I was doing with
Kareem abdul-jabbar he's got a lot of
great cast the way they put it together
at the end it's just god-awful
yeah it's pretty bad god-awful then I'm
gonna tell you what's even worse game
with that two three four five God they
started you know who sold those
milkiness like I want to know to Chinese
guys in the room we got a great idea
they milk everything man and they melt
it and then you could tell that Brit in
the books and you know the other day Bob
Levin has sent me a book that is just
phenomenal I'm Bruce Wayne and it's like
how many books aren't they written about
this guy 40 years born on him being dead
by one they're 73 83 93 2003 2013 we're
talking about this guy's been dead 45
[ __ ] years and they're still coming
ours I was 10 when he died nice that's
why he it just destroyed my inside but I
still remember those that year and a
half later of what like his real fans
were going through like people going
through we were just getting suckered
it's like when I see you know cause
everybody wanted to find the next Bruce
Lee and I'm not putting nobody down here
I'm just telling you how I come like
this yeah really - we said that you
rerelease Appetite for Destruction what
what what you know and we'll do that
like how many [ __ ] be the ones that
they rereleased man we're just idiots we
just keep rebinding the [ __ ]
but nothing bothers me more we take a a
dead person that it's not his voice and
the family has money but they do stupid
things to really slap a fan in the
[ __ ] face right now the Ralphie may
should start to come out like you know
they're trying to sell his jacket for
$50,000 and all this [ __ ] and it
infuriates me
it burns my [ __ ] [ __ ] so now they
release like some [ __ ] you know like
some what do you call those things when
you don't put the [ __ ] name down and
they donate money and you IndieGoGo goal
what's the other one go fund me go go
fund me and go fund me for like a
special of Ralphie May that some chick
taped like follow him around when
Ralphie was his worst you know Ralphie
struggled with a lot of [ __ ] things
at the end he struggled with a lot of
inner demons he struggled with his
divorce he struggled with just [ __ ]
you know what comes with this [ __ ]
you know people think that you go to
these clubs and people love you and the
whole thing but there's a completely
different side of this you know there's
a political side of it and this [ __ ] you
got to deal with in your office and you
don't know Baba but they paid them then
the agents of deposit and now the check
that they were gonna give use a
different amount you know all the
aggravation is that go with it so is
this a combination thing but it's just
so weird that they released a book on
Ralphie May that he he barely [ __ ] em
saying like they just took it and just
to make money like yeah so it's like a
brother and a fan to Ralphie May you
know last week we had when I taped the
thing for Netflix we took Oviedo I tried
to honor him by taking movie then he
promised her Vegas for a weekend and I
promised and we went we had a great time
with luque and I'm gonna take the kid
and the daughter and maybe put some type
of account together and put like a
dollar in there every month I don't
[ __ ] arm it'll work this just so when
they get to be 18 I could give them
something back like the father helped me
you know the father gave me that [ __ ]
stand the father gave me a thousand
dollars ten times the way I give you a
joint
I don't know how many times Ralphie gave
me money without even asking you have
been broken you want to ask me for money
for 20 bucks and they give you money
before you even ask them like that I
here put this in your pocket like [ __ ]
thank God I didn't have to ask you and
he would never go to Joey Alvarado go
I just gave 100 bucks that [ __ ]
miserable but he wouldn't do that he
gave it to you because he wanted to give
it to you from [ __ ] his heart I'm
saying like he didn't give it to you and
then brag the people I fed Joey for a
month know that what don't feed Joey if
you're gonna tell people just feed them
he's [ __ ] friends you know yeah so
it's just so weird that you get these
emails or people trying to exploit one
of your friends yeah and now it takes me
back to like when I was a kid now I felt
about like Bruce Lee you know like they
just they just [ __ ] me in the ass
I would pay for these pictures there
wouldn't be Bruce Lee it would be
somebody else sent from China it was a
ripoff they just rip off people you ever
see that movie they call me Bruce and
you know like some spoof some Bruce Lee
stuff was okay once they started coming
out with the cat noises his [ __ ] that
would [ __ ] piss me to [ __ ] off on it
yeah the one dude didn't bother me there
was one Bruce leaf look-alike that came
out his name was Toronto the Hong Kong
cat I've never heard that he had new
Chuck's beat this something different to
his new chucks
he put [ __ ] copper piping of his new
chucks at the bottom Jesus so when you
hit somebody
so you ever go to a hardware store you
just had four copper piping and you weld
onto a pipe you was just [ __ ] crazy
glue it to the bottom of the [ __ ]
octagon new Chuck or just a broom handle
or everybody in those days is walking
around with bumps in the back of his
head and black and booze is on the
elbows because that's what you did when
you first started new chucks
that's all you did this move here always
that new Chuck came up and hit me in the
face [ __ ] around with the [ __ ] yeah
everybody [ __ ] around with new toys
because
I'm saying so talk to me about the
certification what do they do next
next Saturday they go there what time
it's gonna start at 7:00 in the morning
Saturday morning eat it with everything
oh no I'm gonna get him some acai for
sure okay so it's gonna it'll it'll last
from 7:00 in the morning to probably
about 5:00 in the afternoon both days
and you cover yet you do it let's have
no [ __ ] it's a lot of cover man you know
because I want people to to feel like
they're able to teach it you know
afterwards so um I mean I make it really
simple I have a simple formula I used
simple protocols to teach you know and
if you follow those protocols it's
really easy this is about remembering
the name of the exercises and and me
teaching them how to do it properly and
safely and whatnot you know it is a lot
of information though that's part of
that challenge you know is you got to
study for it and then it's two days of
like almost 16 hours of training you
know how do they study for you shut down
a pamphlet yeah like so like once you
register I'll send you some study
material some videos and and some
documents that you can go over just to
look at the routines because I let I
give them like a list of all the
routines that they have to know and all
the exercises you know they study it so
like most of the time the people that
that do it they have experience doing it
already you know they've been doing it
for a little while so they do you know
it runs really smoothly but yeah it's a
lot of material but part of it is like
it's like a challenge you know to like
two days of kettlebell and bodyweight
train it's pretty brutal mess so it's
gonna test your will a little bit as
well you know but that's part of part of
the fun too you know it's like doing
like a Spartan Race or something like
that you know something intense like
physical activity like that you know so
yeah so my goal is just uh just for
people to be able to feel comfortable
teaching it afterwards that's my goal
it's really where you turn me on to the
Turkish get up if I love the Turkish go
yeah I like I love it too but I do it
differently well I think the Turkish get
up honestly with a kettlebell is one of
the best that's just I agree man it's
and it's gonna I love it it'll warm up
sometimes if I just do that body weight
body weight Turkish without yeah body
weight no nice listening you do five on
each side
there's no stop this is tremendous
tonight yeah he here eating there this
is treat that is a Vegas it's called
Viva Las Vegas is free that you're
getting you're getting the effects of
those buffets right now man I don't do
buffets that's [ __ ] those buffets I
don't do that [ __ ] the best she now but
like what I did it one time in Vegas and
I've paid the price for on the way bar
you see the nails this [ __ ] Lee goes
paint with his girlfriend homes they
drive to Vegas to go to a buffet but
what you don't want to smell my hands
look we buffet food without the waiters
bite the bread and put it back and leave
every in my favor you fellas dog I swear
to God if I beat another buff a four
times it's been a lot my 55 years in
Vegas when you were broke
I don't go downstairs I had Joe Rogan
[ __ ] crazy you're on the road with
girag it dog
one time at the roof when they had the
dirty show at the river that dirty
shelter used to have a dirty short
derivative that he liked yeah it was a
dirty you could go up there take your
dick out and jump up and down and check
off on people it was an hour show
midnight show 12:00 12:15 the opener
12:15 - you know like 1:00 o'clock
because of the headliner and the Rogen
took me one time and the guy gave me the
key through the employee cafeteria hmm
and I was broke as [ __ ] and I went bad
and I look at that food and it was
[ __ ] disgusting
uh-huh I think all I could eat was like
a cheese sandwich
oh that's it oh my god I drank a free
soda see that show bar rescue
yes I got your he goes and it's [ __ ]
it's funny man like oh you have to like
yeah you trust people
[ __ ] yeah these restaurants around here
just do he is the king of going into
soffel [ __ ] this video that asian
woman
catching those birds and putting them in
a plastic bag she got arrested for
cooking them yeah cause dumplings you
eat mmm I told you I know I can't get
dumplings anymore you ruin them for me I
didn't roll
I tried to tell you not to go down there
well the one you have to tell me about
was but Dan went down here but then
killed himself so those [ __ ] things
don't look too good no more do this
right or wrong it's tough to sell those
[ __ ] coochie [ __ ] cat fiddles now
in a time machine I wouldn't go down any
one of those [ __ ] things if you paid
me you God knows what in that ball of
meat oh [ __ ] that day that's what I
don't like no no no this guy we're good
now I'm mundane Paul I don't give a [ __ ]
what she likes
I like that as far as that lizard place
around but no idea they're filthy
Mexican people were there the first time
I moved up here I went to the wine I
just mentioned it no why this is great
you can lift weights and go around the
corner it was like I said [ __ ] the
n-word the whole place looked at me like
don't go in there they serve like a
Jaguar in there like four years ago to
some Wadi and they got six do we hang
our [ __ ] they said like they think
there was fake meat and one day well you
know it's this guy comes up and said my
place is great that's why it's not great
but second of all if they didn't do that
that would be yeah they have the
internet now there's no you could pay
the taste at all yes you can't Yelp you
could pay news articles like hey look
for my [ __ ] kidnapping go look for
the news article when I kidnapped by if
you find it finding whatever it was in
2000 Matt disappears we're gonna believe
some [ __ ] the article or 20 people at
the YMCA look there's 20 people they
probably thought that I work in there
you could just you know I could tell
little things right look at your glass I
see fingerprints on your glass to enter
your place that means you're a filthy
[ __ ] animals and the people are
working for your filthy [ __ ] animals
because they have no initiative I see 20
pieces of [ __ ] finger tips on your
[ __ ] restaurant glass I don't go in
there
yeah that's a hostess's job to wipe that
fingerprint
you never did a little things that show
you you learn men like men they have to
do a lot of cleaning a lot to have a
restaurant I want to be cross it takes a
lot for me to go to a bar and eat little
water I can soak bars those crazy onion
rings I had that since I was a kid
you'll go back then look at the
bartender I'll let the guy that's
cooking mmm take a look at the guy
that's cooking in those bar jobs you
could tell they're not [ __ ] know Phi
Beta Kappa I have no [ __ ] I'm no
genius here but those guys I mean like
now nowadays they're getting some like
and those like gastro problem something
getting some like really legit chefs no
oh no in those pubs this show I think
yeah but you're paying for it but I
don't want to go to some like those
[ __ ] bar go crazy and half of those
places were around this area huh take
the one bar that he went to
I got we do Cui's do calm me down there
where they were [ __ ] scraping look
the rats whatever we used to calm me
down and then they went back to being
filthy and they tried to get bar rescue
to come back and they tell me gonna [ __ ]
all those places there was another place
that bar rescue went to embolden not the
place that remember when Red Bank got
mugged by the magician pose or something
like that red who like Wizard somebody
[ __ ] with black wizard who the [ __ ]
either it's ready some men robbed them
what happen unless what I mean the
rapper red man no no I'll come to either
your friend of ours he works at your
rogue and a little red band whatever his
name was out of bright red bad Brian
yeah his name is Brian Redman he was
date they did a bunch of bars in Burbank
got a bunch of bars locally yeah yeah
yeah they all went back to being filthy
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so don't matter
bro if you're a filthy [ __ ] I can
just tell there's a Cuban place on
Victory down the clock Marlboros yeah
mumbles yeah it's mono then yeah yeah
that's the other place in one there no
Direction no on Victory I know where you
talking about it's right there before
the yes yeah across from Costco cross
yeah Mambo is Glendale the other
direction of victory uh-huh if you're
the other direction of victory you're
the Costco up to the corner looking
across the street this Costco make a
rule
you share McDonald's when you make look
to the left is a McDonald's there's a
Cuban joint net hmm I went there for
mercy's back yes yes the last two times
over there was so filthy oh and the food
was so [ __ ] old but piss me off was
the amount of fingerprints on the glass
it had been like a week and a half since
they had cleaned that so you mean to
tell me that one employee in this place
at the initiative to wipe that glass
down something that's one of my pet
peeves is right see something on the
floor and nobody picks it up hmm then
you walk past a man you know I was doing
that [ __ ] in the ocean today dude I was
in Long Beach I broke through start
reaching and I was like swimming in the
water and I was like man I can't just
sit here and look at this [ __ ] straw
in the ocean you know brother look
there's [ __ ] plastic and [ __ ] so I
was like I'll grab it and I just [ __ ]
had it like go throw it away and I'd
come back and I did that a few times
today man because [ __ ] people just
don't appreciation man it's [ __ ] all
kinds of [ __ ] that in that water you
know I try to be crazy when I see people
walk pass on yeah yeah like the same
thing like at the gym man you know like
all that tape they put on the shitty
[ __ ] ends up on the floor and I just
can't look it I got to pick it up man
throw it away take the initiative and
clean that [ __ ] up man yeah the
restaurant business it's no joke man you
got to be on top of all that stuff
otherwise you you know they come in and
they inspect you and then they [ __ ]
find you but let me tell you something
he let me taste them before they inspect
you they call you and tell you they're
coming that's why if you see a
restaurant they don't have an A rating
you can't do business with because you
know I'm coming it's not like I just
show up on a Tuesday they tell you they
coming mmm they give you adequate date
to get all your stuff right and then
guess what when you don't have it ready
they give you another notice and they
give you time to get it ready so you
don't get it ready you're basically a
filthy [ __ ] animal but sometimes in
the la rating system it's a B because of
simple little things so you have to look
into it like sometimes don't be scared
don't let the rating right some of the
best times I've ever got this from
Mexican do with dirty hands Hey
well I see a baby with gloves on that's
not gonna be a good you I'm saying I see
a skinny chef I don't do business with
that guy adds a little axe I want to see
a fat [ __ ] Michelle you show me a fat
chef that's a chef show me a guy that's
got trying to do kettlebells he's a chef
that's what a chef that's a poster boy
I'm saying I did something by you know
what the bestop will you get I gotta be
in a street corner and the guy's gonna
have filthy hands grease soda
Iseman I gotta take you to my favorite
vegan taco place I wouldn't go with you
if you [ __ ] it's not it's not it's
not a place it's a pop-up he's
everything you just said yeah hurry
hurry oh hey Terry
Lord Papa Papa Papa Papa that is like uh
like they have these like little pop-up
restaurants well though though they send
up a tent in front of like the musically
gypsies don't even your restaurant I'm
gonna be able to come back the next day
and complain you're leavin you don't
like little taco trucks on the side of
the road like that unless they come with
a big-time reputation you know why ma'am
I have a I've always been disgusted by
food Spanish people call it uncle I mean
when I call there's certain things that
are [ __ ] filthy to me like this if
there was a girl I don't want to mention
nationality she was
I love the Dutch when I was she was
filthy and because of her nationality I
don't mean her food because she was
filthy she wouldn't wash dishes and
nothing pisses me off more than that but
to the point where I would see little
flies in the air a little gnats
yeah and she would cook and I go there
hungry now I never ate her food because
I know she was filthy good [ __ ] but she
was just filthy so I'm one of those
people I don't look at different things
I don't like a lot of weird stuff man
too many moving parts I don't do it and
I'm like that with Cuban food I'm very
hip occur very critical Cuban Italian
food very critical because I grew up
around it huh I grew up around I grew up
with good food yeah I'm Brett you know I
don't have a lot of good assets but one
thing is I know a good [ __ ]
restaurant
and I know when I go to that because I
don't judge a restaurant just by the
food I judge it by the overall value I
want to feel then like I ate great but I
also what I spent was worth the value
mmm and then food today you get what you
pay for you know you know when you eat a
dollar stake in Vegas you're not getting
a great a state that's takes been three
weeks old this new market they dip it in
a chemical gets picked again and you
either for a dollar before it gets all
before they throw it away
that's [ __ ] so much you get what you
pay for this and this world you really
do get what you pay for
yeah I think it here thank you sure so
you have to be very careful with what
you eat and I've been like this you know
who is still dissing me well you gotta
remember one thing bro I'm being the fat
[ __ ] I don't need fast food hmm
I'm not a fast food guy I just started
going back to me down with five years
ago because of my daughter before that I
haven't walked into McDonald's it's
gotta be it was 25 [ __ ] years because
I was no loud cause that door professor
now we're getting [ __ ] every plate
that comes in was the lid down they want
to land now now Tom Cruise wants to land
this [ __ ] plane I wasn't allowed to
eat fast food as a child so I did I
didn't touch fast food so I was probably
18 mm Wendy's chicken sandwich was the
first bad fast-food I would sneak a
[ __ ] Big Mac I thought when I went to
Miami cuz when my aunt and my cousins
were loud he can take you fried chicken
and make McDonald's huh
but I didn't tell my mother I would eat
it at all she would not allow me to tell
you fried chicken yes I got old I liked
it that I wouldn't walk into Kentucky
friendlier those chickens are [ __ ]
disgusting aw man all that fast food is
you know it's not I'm a fat [ __ ] I'm not
an advocate philippi yeah I think you
got to do yourself a little bit better
you know if you're gonna eat eat the
best like if I'm gonna eat salami me
boys and I'm gonna go with the best I'm
like a salami from [ __ ] Subway my
mommy's Joe Jersey Mike's all these
shitty [ __ ] chains you know yeah I
try to get the babies you love Jersey
Mike's you gonna get cancer get good
cancer
you can swap what is the what is the
seminar certification it's this up this
coming weekend 21st and 22nd Saturday
and Sunday listen if you live in the air
all day long if you live in the area you
love don't in an area you can still if
you don't live in the area if you love
fitness if you really love your body if
you want a different attack to it this
is this is the guy to do it you know I
took a lot of your exercises you know IG
combed out it man I used those bats take
for my shoulders I used those bats once
a week for recovery for my shoulders
marlborough I do the kettlebell swings
up the bats and I twist my wrist and I
do all that
so I borrow from a different couple
different groups that's Bruce Lee's
philosophies
take what it's useful and discard what
see Lee and I used to go to a kettlebell
place that that guy was very good he was
a padlock basedgod Pavel but then we
went to a different place where the guy
was a jerk off base guy and he was
making this through jerk off exercises
and in fact he was hurting us yeah now
in the main site we would get hurt
because I haven't been going there [ __ ]
till Friday you got to know how to use a
mouse because like if you're [ __ ] up
your students and hurting your students
they're not gonna come back come back
you know so I learned that a long time
ago man is how to warm up properly about
this so so such a big part of kettlebell
training that's why like when people see
those workouts on Instagram they asked
me all kinds of questions and they want
to go do it I'm like hey man remember we
we do a whole warm-up before we do this
you know right it's it's very scary
because I go to a few I've got like
three different gyms now for different
reasons and I see people doing it in a
way that I was taught you're gonna get
hurt doing that yeah and I look at me I
can't tell anyone to like not work out a
certain way but now it like you can get
really like there were people that I
work out what they got really hurt back
probably my Achilles for a while was
hurting and I had to adjust and and rest
for a while I thought it snap yeah for
sure dude if you don't know what you're
doing you try to teach somebody some
kettlebell [ __ ] and you [ __ ] up their
back and then their back could be [ __ ]
up for life I tell people all the time
before you [ __ ] with kettlebells go work
with so
okay with some three instruction three
to not don't because a lot of people
think YouTube is instruction yeah I want
you even if let's say I like Joey ah
Bravo's workout hmm but I live in
[ __ ] Cleveland mmm telling Joey
Alvarado's work I've looked at it I
could do it
there's somebody in the area I can do a
private with yeah it's always good to
get some hands-on training absolutely
good just to get to look at you better
to research them and ask them where they
get their training right you gotta go on
their website and research everybody men
like and it's aids you know look them up
on YouTube look home and see what
they're doing and see who see who
they're training to you know like a lot
there's a lot of all these cannibal
experts out there man and you look at
them and you see them on the Instagram
doing all kinds of stuff but you never
see him training anybody and I mean the
people were like in the in the trenches
like me every day teaching people I
teach people it's my profession you know
so I know how to do it you know it's
there's there's a lot to it
you know so find out find out a
qualified person to teach you the basics
and teach you how to warm up and teach
you the the mechanics of the exercise
and stuff like that too you know it's
really important very important with
anything now same thing when you just
say you're not gonna [ __ ] learn
jujitsu off a [ __ ] YouTube video
right people do it people I know I can
imagine that you paid through it yeah I
mean they do it with gettable they do
what every barbels everything man they
used to looking on you doing then try to
do it but like you know didn't have
Intel the teaching somehow to fight from
watching [ __ ] videos oh man I've
learned how to do a bunch of [ __ ]
watching videos I got more confused than
when I was when I walk I keep it simple
yeah yeah then that's the thing is like
sometimes with jujitsu you know people
want to learn everything at once so they
start watching videos and they start
getting so deep that they can't even
remember the fundamentals you know I
mean so like the those jujitsu videos
and stuff like that cuz they could
actually hurt you know you know like
because it's just so much information
you can't process everything about you
JIT so once you know so you should
always just like kettlebell you should
establish that foundation at first when
I could get those basics down and then
build off of that
so you teach this Mondays Wednesdays and
Fridays I teach I teach in six days a
week so like alright cuz your days are
at ten oh no no no
the Tuesdays and Thursdays 6:30 p.m. and
Saturdays at 10:00 a.m. - kettle bell
and I know that other than that like
it's all jiu-jitsu I teach you just as
well so I mean you're covered refreshing
I will be his buddies here from out of
town right now one of his best friends
from Brazil his name is Alessandra
he's a like a fourth degree and he's
been covering the classes but he's gonna
go to New York so I'll I'll be covering
the UM the the noon classes and all that
stuff so you've a Saturday 10 a.m.
Saturday 10:00 a.m. man that's a good
one it's a good one man it's a cool time
you know you can sleep in a little bit
then make it over there yeah sure dude
tell me it was a good time fine there's
a lot of times I wake up before 3:00 I'm
like I'm gonna go see professor [ __ ]
that most heart attacks happening from
5:30 to the lunchtime [ __ ] that yeah
that's well no that's oh I got to be
careful I'm 55 leave me [ __ ] in the
mortars no [ __ ] ice conserve your
energy no cuz your heart beats too much
I get too worked up in the morning so I
kind of stopped yeah I can't even give
my wife a stabbing no more in the
morning sighs he's gotta keep it simple
none of the boy I don't do nothing don't
like 9 o'clock really cook it I'm saying
yeah I appreciate thank you for coming
out thank you for coming what's YouTube
but they can find if you just like
Google kettle jitsu all my social media
and everything will come up this guy's
one of my all-time favorites man that's
why I put him on the show
you think the user we love you man you
miss Chris Cornell man I do like I to be
honest with you like I still kind of
have a hard time like when uh when a
song comes up on the radio man that's I
have a hard time listening to it a
little bit you know because it kind of
hurt it hurts a little bit you know I
got did you ever see a picture of me and
it was in Sweden Sweden Rome when I was
Ella's in a layover and um I was just
walking and he walks right past me I was
like holy [ __ ] I was like Chris Cornell
and he turns around he looks at me
and first of all like [ __ ] this man is
[ __ ] tall but that's the first time I
was ever starstruck and like like since
I was starstruck he looked even like
bigger and larger than life and I was
just like you know me man I like to talk
but like I I I was trying to tell him
how much his music meant to me and I
think maybe I did I don't know but I
felt like I was stuttering I couldn't
figure I felt stupid he's got
like grinning like hey thanks man and he
took a he took a picture with me and men
that was pretty awesome but yeah I do
miss him man it's crazy when somebody
dies like Prince died you know yeah
Michael Jackson died I miss him I miss
everybody you know he's like you listen
to the music
no I can't believe they're gone but
Chris Cornell whenever I hear like their
dad listen to bad motor thing is my show
that's you know I love Superunknown
yeah yeah yeah I love Superunknown I
think that motor finger was the first
album where they just they got it
everything together that was the Chinese
got going on for Badmotorfinger yeah I
can tell yeah no no he's a guitar player
but for the first time they have a
Chinese baby no no no yeah yeah Hiro
Yamamoto yes left after louder than love
I think the first one now the first one
was ultra mega ultra mega okay yeah for
that yeah and they had a couple IP
before that and Hiro Yamamoto and then
after that they were interchanging they
had Jason Everman that he actually used
to be in Nirvana back in the day okay
the guy with like hit like long curly
hair kind of like Kris Munroe but it was
like red and they had him through the UM
like louder than love tour cuz I saw
them in Germany together actually met
them back then and I had a small little
Club too and then after that that's when
they got um what's his name been um
[ __ ] awesome bass player now he owned
it when I lived in Seattle he owned the
club somebody owned the club either the
bass player or the drummer
oh really yeah owned the club right Matt
Cameron that's the drummer for
Soundgarden drummer ever
somebody owned the club like two doors
down from our friend Josh wolf Club you
he ran a level Loco mhm and they were on
the same block I never went in there and
you don't want to embarrass myself I
mean oh wait I don't know nobody nobody
ever no no but nothing
I Love You professor have a great week
don't forget you it'll be there this for
Saturday Sunday 7:00 a.m. like I said if
you're looking for something that
something different to push your Heights
we're gonna change your violin when we
get healthy this is the guy to do it I
mean we've been dear friends for years
and I used while of his principles he
turned me on for the turkeys [ __ ] get
up and now I love it don't forget as
usual
supplements whether it's [ __ ] what do
you think I did this morning when I got
up I had breakfast and I popped three
shroom tech immune to why cuz I'm
getting on a plane with a bunch of
filthy [ __ ] animals see Japanese
people they put my gas mask on and
prepare these filthy [ __ ] people me I
take [ __ ] and shroom tech immune and
before I workout tomorrow morning I'll
be shrimp export and [ __ ] during the
week after my little work actually think
it is it's a Mexican chocolate the whey
protein why cuz I believe in on I
believe in their supplements go to Allah
calm right now I'm press in church BAM
and get 10% off delivered right to your
[ __ ] door
that's a bus clean there's something
that's out there trust from Tanya number
two you're looking for mats for your
little garage you wanna throw some
people around you looking for shin
guards iMovie Thai you're looking for
nice gloves you looking for the [ __ ]
best gear out there you know me dawg I'm
a Fuji sports guy all the way to the end
I love Fuji I had a couple other games
that were heavy Fuji is just right
whether you go for the [ __ ] 96 89 $79
G or you want to help your game with the
cycle to read we've done the Saporito or
the [ __ ] elemental Fugees the way to
[ __ ] go they're light they're tough
and they'll [ __ ] take a beating you
understand me
for the Fuji sports.com right now and
press in church damn and get 10% off
delivered to your house plus you're
helping out the church alright I'm gonna
thank professor Joey I've arrived I want
to thank the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys without you guys I have oh gods
dick
nothing it's Monday morning go out there
and show them that you're gonna [ __ ]
them up this week you're gonna blow up
the outside world you bad [ __ ]
it's all about you take them to the hoop
who gives a [ __ ] about what they're
thinking it's about what you're thinking
alright
stay black have a good week and we'll
see your Wednesday morning tip top Magoo
ready to go have a great [ __ ] day
kick that [ __ ] melee